Hey everybody, how's it going? We have a really killer episode here. I've heard the term WebAssembly a lot. I've done a little bit of studying on it, but we have an expert, Kevin Hoffman, the CTO of Cosmotic on the show to really dive deep and explain kind of what WebAssembly is, how it's useful, why it exists, and what kind of things it can provide for you. So thanks so much for coming on the show, Kevin. Thanks for having me. Appreciate it.
大家好，最近怎么样？我们今天有一集非常精彩的节目。我经常听到WebAssembly这个词，也稍微研究过它，但今天我们请到了Cosmotic的首席技术官Kevin Hoffman这位专家做客节目，来深入探讨并解释WebAssembly究竟是什么、它有什么用、它为什么存在，以及它能为你提供什么样功能。非常感谢你能来参加节目，Kevin。谢谢邀请，我很荣幸。
Cool. So how has Cosmonaut been handling the pandemic? Has it changed the sort of work style? Is Cosmonaut remote already, or did you have to go remote? What was that like? I think technically Cosmonautic may have actually been formed after the pandemic started. Oh, nice. Okay. We would have been entirely remote regardless. So it really hasn't changed too much of our team dynamic. We just spend all day on Zoom and Google Meet. So what is it like to start a company in the middle of a pandemic? I mean, it's kind of hard to get that firm handshake, like with among the co-founders and kickoff. Everything really just has to be done over Zoom,
太好了。那么Cosmonaut是如何应对疫情的？它改变了工作方式吗？Cosmonaut本来就是远程办公，还是说你们后来转成了远程？那是一种怎样的体验？我想技术上讲，Cosmonautic可能真的是在疫情开始之后才成立的。哦，这样啊。好吧。不管怎样，我们本来就全员远程。所以它其实并没有对我们的团队动态产生太大改变。我们只是整天泡在Zoom和Google Meet上。那么在疫情期间创立一家公司是什么体验？我是说，要在创始成员之间来个坚定的握手并启动项目其实挺难的。一切都只能通过Zoom进行，
right? Yeah. When we first got going and we had an off site with the founding members, and so we got a little bit of in-person contact although it was you know six feet apart well there might be advantages to that i mean i i think that if you're six feet apart you can't reach over and strangle that person when uh you know the contract doesn't come in and and uh you know the code doesn't work and you have i think a startup from what i've heard from friends of mine who have started companies it's like extraordinarily it's the ultimate test of your bonds with these folks. Yeah. Six feet apart gives other people an unfair advantage.
对吧？对。当我们刚开始的时候，创始成员们进行了一次线下聚会，所以我们确实有了一点面对面的接触，尽管你知道那是保持了六英尺的社交距离。好吧，这可能也有好处，我的意思是，我认为如果你保持六英尺的距离，当合同没谈成，或者代码运行不通时，你就没法伸手去掐住那个人的脖子。据我从创立公司的朋友那里听来的，创业极其……这是对你与这些伙伴之间纽带的终极考验。是的。保持六英尺的距离给其他人带来了一种不公平的优势。
They have a head start. Yeah, right. Nice. Cool. Yeah. So Cosmonic is one of the companies that's like, I don't want to say sponsoring because it's a CNCF project, but it's sort of what would be the verb you'd use for how you're catering to WasmCloud? Maybe fostering. Fostering. That's a good word. Fostering WasmCloud. Fostering WasmCloud. So let's rewind the clock a little bit and kind of walk us through what kind of your career path was. What inspired you to say, let's do this, let's start Cosmotic, and let's make this a real thing?
他们抢先一步了。是的，没错。太好了。酷。是的，所以Cosmonic是一家类似于……我不想说是赞助，因为它是一个CNCF项目，但类似于……你会用什么动词来形容你们对WasmCloud的支持？也许是培育。培育。这是一个好词。培育WasmCloud。培育WasmCloud。那么让我们把时间倒回一点，跟我们聊聊你的职业生涯路径是怎样的？是什么启发你说，我们来做这个，创立Cosmotic，把它变成现实？
Sure. So I guess it started with a lot of frustration, anger, shouting. Yeah. I can't even remember how many years now, but I've been building microservices and deploying them in large enterprises in one shape or another for many, many years. I worked for Pivotal, and when I worked for them, my role was to teach other companies that we consulted for how to put stuff in the cloud. And so that was even more microservices and splitting up monoliths.
当然。我想这始于大量的沮丧、愤怒和大喊大叫。是的。我甚至记不清是多少年前了，但我多年来一直以各种形式在大型企业中构建微服务并部署它们。我在Pivotal工作过，在那里我的角色是教我们提供咨询的其他公司如何将东西放到云端。所以这就涉及更多的微服务和拆分单体应用。
And I finally just sort of just had it with the amount of repetition and boilerplate and ceremony that was involved in that whole process. And I was just looking for a way to distill what I did down to just writing some business logic and then deploying it and then not having to worry about anything else. And so a couple of years ago, I was working for Capital One and I was looking for, you know, something that would give me that kind of new developer experience where we just focus on the business logic. And, you know, when you're building enterprise apps, normally you spend like 90% of your time
我最终对整个过程中涉及的大量重复、样板代码和繁文缛节感到彻底厌倦了。我只是在寻找一种方法，把我的工作简化为仅仅编写一些业务逻辑，然后部署它，而不必担心其他任何事情。所以几年前，我在Capital One工作，当时我在寻找那种能带来全新开发者体验的东西，让我们只专注于业务逻辑。而且，当你构建企业级应用时，通常90%的时间都花在
on your non-functional requirements, logging, tracing, networking, clients, servers, routing, metrics, all of that stuff. Access to databases, all of that stuff gets bolted on to the business logic. And so I was looking for a way to sort of unbolt that. So that's where, that's when I stumbled on WebAssembly way back in the day when it was,
你的非功能性需求上，比如日志记录、追踪、网络、客户端、服务器、路由、指标等等所有这些。访问数据库，所有这些东西都被附加到了业务逻辑上。所以我一直在寻找一种方法来把这些东西剥离掉。也就是在那时，我偶然发现了WebAssembly，那是很久以前，
when nobody had heard of it. Cool. So, so you mentioned business logic. So when people hear, I mean, when people hear web, you know, they'll think of, you know, people hear web, they'll think of the front end and they'll think of the browser and rendering the HTML and laying it out and maybe video. And so they don't generally think of business logic. They think, oh, that's going to sit on the server somewhere. And so, yeah, what is the role of WebAssembly with respect to sort of business logic and what's the tie in there? Yeah. So what's interesting about WebAssembly is, you know, it's called WebAssembly and most people get introduced to it through the browser. You know,
当时还没人听说过它。太好了。所以，你提到了业务逻辑。当人们听到……我的意思是，当人们听到Web时，你知道，他们会想到前端，会想到浏览器，会想到渲染HTML、布局，可能还有视频。所以他们通常不会想到业务逻辑。他们会想，哦，那肯定是在某个地方的服务器上运行。所以，WebAssembly在业务逻辑方面扮演什么角色？它们之间的联系是什么？是的。关于WebAssembly，有趣的是，你知道，它被称为WebAssembly，大多数人都是通过浏览器了解它的。你知道，
someone has made some flashy demo that does some impressive stuff inside a browser, and WebAssembly gets the credit for it. And so we just naturally assume that WebAssembly is a browser thing. There's all sorts of forum discussions about whether WebAssembly is going to replace JavaScript on the front end and things like that. And I think, you know, obviously for the last couple of years, I've been banking on the idea that WebAssembly is more than that. At its core, it's portable compute. And so if you think about it, like if you're writing code and that code has a side effect, then, you know, it reaches out of the sandbox in order to
有人做了一些炫酷的演示，在浏览器里做了一些令人印象深刻的事情，而WebAssembly就获得了赞誉。所以我们自然而然地认为WebAssembly是浏览器的专利。论坛上有很多关于WebAssembly是否会取代前端JavaScript之类的讨论。我想，显然在过去的几年里，我一直押注于这样一个理念：WebAssembly不仅仅于此。它的核心是可移植的计算。所以如果你仔细想想，如果你在编写代码，并且该代码具有副作用，那么，你知道，它就会突破沙箱，以便
make that side effect happen. And with WebAssembly, it's physically impossible to escape that sandbox. So it's portable, but it has such a limited instruction set that any side effects from the code that you have in your WebAssembly module, those need to come from the host runtime. So if your side effect is manipulating the DOM, then you might have a WebAssembly module that can interact with the browser. In my case, all of my side effects are interacting with distributed stuff from the edge to the cloud. But the core thing to keep in mind about WebAssembly is that it's fast, it's efficient, it's small, it's CPU and OS agnostic, and it has a secure memory sandbox. And it can only do the things that its host gives it permission to do. Oh, interesting. So that reminds me a little
让那个副作用发生。而对于WebAssembly，要逃离这个沙箱在物理上是不可能的。所以它是可移植的，但它的指令集非常有限，以至于你的WebAssembly模块中的代码产生的任何副作用，都需要来自宿主运行时。因此，如果你的副作用是操作DOM，那么你可能会有一个能与浏览器交互的WebAssembly模块。就我而言，我所有的副作用都是与从边缘到云端的分布式事物进行交互。但关于WebAssembly，需要记住的核心点是：它速度快、效率高、体积极小、与CPU和操作系统无关，并且拥有安全的内存沙箱。而且它只能做它的宿主允许它做的事情。哦，有意思。所以这让我想起了一点
bit touches a lot of different things. I mean, one is, you know, definitely, we've all written, you know, maybe in high school or in college, we've all written that's the first time I implemented a linked list, uh did know what i was doing and all of a sudden you know the characters on the console were you know some like weird you know acrylic characters like i'd somehow like broken the terminal or just i'm writing to random memory and getting really weird errors and so and so that's that's because you know in something like really low level like c you just have total authority to do anything in that process access anything and so you can easily kind of shoot yourself in the foot and so unless you're doing things like like what patrick does where it's it's really low level
涉及很多不同的方面。我的意思是，首先，毫无疑问，我们都写过，可能是在高中或大学里，我们都写过——那是我第一次实现链表，当时根本不知道自己在做什么，突然间，你知道，控制台上的字符就变成了一些奇怪的、你知道的字符，就像我不知怎么搞坏了终端，或者只是在向随机内存写入数据并得到非常奇怪的错误。所以，那是因为在像C这样非常底层的东西中，你对该进程中的任何事情都有绝对的控制权，可以访问任何东西，所以你很容易搬起石头砸自己的脚。因此，除非你在做像帕特里克那样的事情——它非常底层，
and and uh and you need really speed and performance but for most of us like we you know have something where you know i couldn't i couldn't really break everything and that way you can kind of work in the inside of one of these sort of sandboxes. And so, so one way of thinking about a sandbox is, is, you know, as you move to something like, let's say, Python, for example, or even Java or something where you're not manipulating the memory directly, then you can't just go to, or at least like easily go to like a specific point in the memory of the Python VM. And so you lose that, that, that sort of real flexibility, but in exchange, like you have something that you can kind of rely on, especially when you're working in a big group. And so you're
而且你需要极高的速度和性能，但对于我们大多数人来说，我们希望有一些东西，你知道，我不会轻易把所有东西都弄坏，这样你就可以在其中一个沙箱内部工作。所以，考虑沙箱的一种方式是，你知道，当你转向像Python这样的语言，甚至是Java或者其他你不直接操作内存的语言时，你就不能随便去，或者至少不能轻易地去到Python虚拟机内存中的某个特定点。于是你失去了那种真正的灵活性，但作为交换，你拥有了一种可以依赖的东西，特别是当你和一大群人一起工作时。所以你在
saying, then, you know, you can think of Docker or like a virtual end for these, you know, vagrants is like these kinds of things too, where they're creating these, these very isolated containers. And in that container, you get sort of reproducibility and a lot of things because you've limited the number of side effects. And so, and so then I, and I think about sort of like Android where you ask for permissions. And so you can't, for example, accidentally blow away someone's contact list if you're writing an app that doesn't have the contact permission. And so is that when you when you talk about the sandbox impressions, is that kind of what you're talking about? So so so your WASM, your WebAssembly program, you know, if you haven't explicitly told it, you have access to the microphone.
说，你可以把Docker或虚拟机（如Vagrant）也看作是这种东西，它们正在创建这些高度隔离的容器。在那个容器中，你可以获得某种可复现性以及很多特性，因为你限制了副作用的数量。所以，我想到了安卓系统，你需要请求权限。因此，例如，如果你编写的应用没有联系人权限，你就不会不小心抹掉别人的联系人列表。所以，当你谈到沙箱权限时，这正是你在谈论的吗？所以你的WASM，你的WebAssembly程序，如果你没有明确告诉它你有麦克风权限，
They can't accidentally turn on the microphone. Yeah, so all of the things that you said about sandboxing apply to WebAssembly in some form. So there's some low-level stuff, and I don't know if you're all that interested in it, but some of the security stuff that comes from WebAssembly prevents things like the most common causes of CVEs. So you can't do buffer overrun failures.
它就不可能意外打开麦克风。是的，你关于沙箱所说的一切，在某种形式上都适用于WebAssembly。所以有一些底层的东西，我不知道你是不是对它很感兴趣，但WebAssembly带来的一些安全性可以防止最常见的CVE（常见漏洞与披露）起因。所以你不会遇到缓冲区溢出失败。
You can't. Sorry, what's a CVE? A vulnerability, a security alert. Ah, okay. Got it. for people to attack processes is to trick it into reading past some piece of its own memory so that it will start executing instructions that you've placed in there so that you can then, you know, use it to go and borrow its privileges or pretend to be that process or, you know, exfiltrate data from it with webassembly
你不能。抱歉，什么是CVE？一个漏洞，一个安全警报。啊，明白了。人们攻击进程的一种方式是诱骗它读取其自身内存的一部分之外的内容，以便它开始执行你放置在那里的指令，然后你就可以利用它来借用其特权，或者冒充该进程，或者从中窃取数据。对于WebAssembly，
it's physically impossible to do that there is no way to give a webassembly piece of code an arbitrary instruction to run so if it wasn't compiled into the module when the module was built it'll never run it it also has when ites memory, it never accesses the host's memory. It only accesses what amounts to a big, long, giant array of bytes. And it's given that array of bytes as a playground. And it can, you know, the code inside can use it for whatever heap operations it wants. But that's it. The WebAssembly module can't reach out through the host and see what the host is doing or access other modules that are running.
在物理上是不可能做到这一点的。根本没有办法给WebAssembly代码一段要运行的任意指令。因此，如果它在模块构建时没有被编译进模块中，它就永远不会运行。而且当它访问内存时，它永远不会访问宿主机的内存。它只能访问相当于一个巨大、漫长、庞大的字节数组的东西。这个字节数组被作为它的游乐场。里面的代码可以将其用于它想要的任何堆操作，但仅此而已。WebAssembly模块无法通过宿主向外窥探宿主在做什么，也无法访问正在运行的其他模块。
Even things like printing text to the console, that's not physically possible. In WebAssembly, if you build it in what's called standalone or freestanding mode, you don't even have an instruction to print to the console. Oh, interesting. You have to agree on some protocol with the host in order to do your I.O. Now, there's a sort of a second level standard for WebAssembly called WASI, which is the WebAssembly system interface. That has almost like a POSIX-like contract between the host and WebAssembly where you get some low level Unix-like functionality, which includes things like being able to write to the console. But even then, the host gets final say. If the host doesn't want the module to write to a particular file descriptor, it's not going to happen.
甚至像在控制台打印文本这样简单的事情，在物理上也是不可能的。在WebAssembly中，如果你以所谓的独立（standalone）或自由（freestanding）模式构建它，你甚至没有打印到控制台的指令。哦，有意思。你必须与宿主就某种协议达成一致才能进行I/O。现在，有一种针对WebAssembly的第二层标准，叫做WASI，即WebAssembly系统接口（WebAssembly System Interface）。它在宿主和WebAssembly之间几乎拥有类似于POSIX的契约，你可以在其中获得一些底层的类Unix功能，包括能够写入控制台等。但即便如此，宿主拥有最终决定权。如果宿主不想让模块写入特定的文件描述符，那就不会发生。
Got it. And so, yeah, can you tie in WebAssembly? So you're talking about going to different companies that had sort of these legacy, you know, I spin up, you know, eight machines that have a zillion cores and these eight machines need to run everything. And so you're going from that to more of like a cloud, you know, microservices, auto scaling, all these things. And so and you were kind of reinventing the wheel over and over again. Right. So how does WebAssembly tie into that? Yeah, so there's almost like this discovery path that people have when they first start tinkering with WebAssembly. You look at it when you first start playing with it.
明白了。所以，你能把WebAssembly结合起来讲讲吗？你之前提到去过一些公司，它们有那种遗留的系统，你知道的，我启动了拥有无数核心的八台机器，而这八台机器需要运行所有东西。所以你要从那种模式转变为更像云、微服务、自动扩展、所有这些东西。而且你一直在重复造轮子。对吧？那么WebAssembly是如何与这些契合的呢？是的，当人们第一次开始琢磨WebAssembly时，几乎会经历一条发现之路。当你刚开始玩它的时候，你会看一下它，
And your first example is, how do I add two numbers in WebAssembly and return the value? And that's super easy to do. It's a pure function. There's no side effects. Everything works fine. But then you try and figure out how to do more robust things, like how do you pass structured data into a WebAssembly module and get structured data out? There's no standard for that. So you have to pick one or like in the case
你的第一个例子是：如何在WebAssembly中将两个数字相加并返回结果？这非常容易做到。这是一个纯函数。没有副作用。一切工作正常。但随后你试图弄清楚如何做更强大的事情，比如如何将结构化数据传入WebAssembly模块并获取结构化数据出来？没有这方面的标准。所以你必须选择一个，或者像
of the Wasm Cloud open source project, we made one. And so then you have the ability to work on more complex data structures. And then from there, the next question people ask is, well, since the Web Assembly module doesn't have instructions for things like writing to the network, then again, WASI is sort of an exception there, but it doesn't have IO and it doesn't have access to web servers or databases or whatever. How do you connect this module to the capabilities that it needs? And there are a number of open source projects that sort of each take a different
WasmCloud开源项目的例子那样，我们自己做一个。然后你就有能力处理更复杂的数据结构。从那里开始，人们问的下一个问题是，既然WebAssembly模块没有像写入网络这样的指令（当然，WASI是一个例外），但它没有I/O，也没有访问网络服务器、数据库或其他东西的权限。你如何将这个模块连接到它所需的功能上？有许多开源项目，它们各自对如何赋能这些WebAssembly模块持有不同的
opinion on how you empower these web assembly modules. So Cloudflare lets you write WebAssembly modules, but the only so-called power that those modules have is the ability to interact with the Cloudflare edge. And that's it. With a project like WasmCloud, we use cryptographic signatures to inject claims right into the module that describe what the module is allowed to do. So is the module allowed to access an HTTP server? Is it allowed to access a SQL database? Can it make web requests? And so those WasmCloud is responsible for connecting these WebAssembly modules securely to these external capabilities. But I think the underlying point there is that anything that you see a WebAssembly module doing
观点。Cloudflare允许你编写WebAssembly模块，但这些模块唯一所谓的“超能力”就是与Cloudflare边缘网络进行交互。仅此而已。而对于像WasmCloud这样的项目，我们使用密码学签名将声明直接注入到模块中，描述该模块被允许做什么。例如：该模块被允许访问HTTP服务器吗？它被允许访问SQL数据库吗？它能发起网络请求吗？因此，WasmCloud负责将这些WebAssembly模块安全地连接到这些外部功能。但我认为其根本点在于，你看到WebAssembly模块做的任何事情，
that is over and above pure calculation, so just running straight up instructions, is either smoke and mirrors, or is work done almost entirely by the host. Got it. So, you know, my background, as opposed to Patrick, my background is mostly writing kind of Python and machine learning things. And so for my mental model of assembly is, it's the thing that my compiler does that lets my program run so when we talk about web assembly is that the right mental model is is is do you write code in something else and then it gets compiled to web assembly is it like an idl like llvm or one of
只要它超出了纯计算的范畴（即不仅仅是运行简单的指令），要么是障眼法，要么几乎完全是由宿主完成的工作。明白了。所以，你知道，我的背景不像帕特里克，我的背景主要是编写Python和机器学习方面的东西。因此，我对汇编的心理模型是：它是编译器干的活儿，能让我的程序运行。所以当我们谈论WebAssembly时，正确的心理模型是什么？你是用别的语言写代码，然后将其编译成WebAssembly吗？它就像LLVM或其中一个IDL那样的接口定义语言吗？或者说WebAssembly到底是什么？所以WebAssembly是一种字节码格式。你知道，
these idls or what is what actually is web assemblysembly? So the WebAssembly is a bytecode format. So, you know, the Java virtual machine is also a bytecode format. And so WebAssembly is a virtual machine. And the instructions for that virtual machine are bytecodes inside your WebAssembly module. And you're right in that the analogy to assembly sort of makes sense because the instructions that are in that module are fairly low level. Nobody wants to write that stuff by hand. You can, and it's probably a useful learning exercise to at least try it once. But once you've experienced that, that's when the college professor says, well, now that you've done it the hard way, here's the real easy way to do it. And the easy way to do it is to take a high
Java虚拟机也是一种字节码格式。因此，WebAssembly是一个虚拟机。而该虚拟机的指令就是你的WebAssembly模块内部的字节码。你说得对，将其与汇编进行类比在某种程度上是合理的，因为该模块中的指令相当底层。没有人愿意手写这些东西。你可以这样做，把它作为一次至少尝试一次的学习练习可能会很有用。但一旦你体验过这一点，大学教授就会说：“既然你已经用困难的方式做完了，这里有一种真正简单的方法。”而简单的方法是采用像Rust这样的大
level language like Rust and compile your Rust code into WebAssembly. There are other languages that support doing that. So you can do it with TinyGo. You can do it with Zig. You can do it with C, C++. There are other languages that are trying to get there, like Python. Fulgo has some issues with WebAssembly. By and large, Rust seems to be where most of the community support is for taking whatever code you've written, using a ton of libraries, and then compiling it into WebAssembly. Right now, Rust has the best experience
级语言，并将你的Rust代码编译成WebAssembly。还有其他语言支持这样做。你可以用TinyGo这样做。你可以用Zig这样做。你可以用C、C++这样做。其他语言也在努力实现这一点，比如Python。Go语言在WebAssembly方面遇到了一些问题。总的来说，对于获取你编写的代码、使用大量库并将其编译成WebAssembly，Rust似乎拥有最多的社区支持。目前，Rust在这方面拥有最好的体验，
on that, but everybody else is sort of on their way to it. Got it. So this is like a separate compiler that you would run. And instead of, I'm assuming that like the traditional Rust compiler, actually, yeah, the traditional Rust compiler you know executable and whatever os it's running on and so you're saying you can take potentially at least some of the same code i mean imagine you had something that was that was um that didn't depend on any io or anything as you said the add function or something you could take that same add function and compile it with the WebAssembly Rust compiler? And what would you get? You would get a binary that can run on the WebAssembly VM. Is that correct?
但其他所有人也都在通往这方面的路上。明白了。所以这是一个你需要运行的独立编译器。而且我假设传统的Rust编译器——实际上，是的，传统的Rust编译器会生成针对它正在运行的操作系统等的32位或64位可执行文件。所以你是说，你可能可以拿来至少部分相同的代码——假设你有一些不依赖任何I/O或其他东西的东西，正如你所说的加法函数或类似的东西——你可以用WebAssembly Rust编译器编译那个相同的加法函数吗？你会得到什么？你会得到一个可以在WebAssembly虚拟机上运行的二进制文件。对吗？
Yep. So in Rust terms, what you would end up doing is choosing WebAssembly as your target. So with Rust, you can target certain platforms or certain other environments. And so Rust has a target called WASM32. Use that target and you get a.wasm file as your output instead of an executable. If you want to target WASI, which is where you get operating system-like access, then you just use Rust to target the WASI, which is where you get operating system-like access, then you just use Rust to target the WASI target. Different compilers are different in terms of how you can use them
是的。用Rust的术语来说，你最终会选择WebAssembly作为你的目标平台（target）。在Rust中，你可以针对某些平台或其他特定环境。所以Rust有一个名为WASM32的目标。使用该目标，你将得到一个.wasm文件作为输出，而不是可执行文件。如果你想针对WASI（可以获得操作系统般访问权限的环境），那么你只需使用Rust针对WASI目标即可。不同的编译器在使用方式上有所不同，
in order to get your WebAssembly code, but what you should get from compiling to WebAssembly is a binary that can be executed by any host on any operating system under any CPU architecture and without modification. And so one of the big promises there is that you get these really small modules that you can just pick up and move wherever you want to move them to. And, you know, one of the, I think the creator of Docker said that if WebAssembly had been around when they were building Docker, they would have just used WebAssembly. Oh, interesting. So how is WebAssembly then different from Python, right? So Python has a VM and you can compile down to these pyc files and the pyc files can run on uh should be yeah it can definitely run on any python vm so you could just built on a windows machine it should run on a linux machine and so it sounds similar what are
以此来获取你的WebAssembly code，但通过编译为WebAssembly，你应该得到一个二进制文件，它可以被任何宿主、在任何操作系统、在任何CPU架构下执行，并且无需修改。因此，其中一个最大的承诺是，你可以获得这些非常小的模块，你可以随意拿起它们，将它们移动到你想移动的任何地方。而且，你知道，Docker的创造者似乎说过，如果WebAssembly在他们构建Docker时就已经存在了，他们就会直接使用WebAssembly。哦，有意思。那么WebAssembly与Python有什么不同呢？Python有一个虚拟机，你可以将其编译为pyc文件，而pyc文件可以在——应该说，是的，它绝对可以在任何Python虚拟机上运行。所以你可以在Windows机器上构建它，它应该也能在Linux机器上运行。所以听起来很相似，
the what are the differences there so what's interesting there is kind of a dichotomy where you have power that you get from limitations. And so the WebAssembly virtual machine format has no native instructions that are CPU specific or OS specific or even make assumptions about the host runtime. So when you compile Java down to bytecode, you still have bytecode instructions that tell Java to access your operating system. That tell it to do things that might need to be translated from you know windows to linux and so the vm needs to know how to do those those translations right like you create a j frame for example and so that will have to do something very different on windows because actually you'll actually draw a frame on your screen and so that j frame you know that whatever that byte code that new j frame call turns into that byte code now needs to know how to do that on every os so the different
它们的区别在哪里？有趣的是，这里存在一种二分法，即你从限制中获得力量。因此，WebAssembly虚拟机格式没有针对特定CPU、特定操作系统甚至不假定宿主运行时的原生指令。所以当你把Java编译成字节码时，你仍然拥有告诉Java访问操作系统的字节码指令。这些指令可能会被转换，你知道，从Windows转换到Linux，所以虚拟机需要知道如何进行这些转换，对吧？例如，你创建一个Jframe，它在Windows上需要做非常不同的事情，因为你实际上需要在屏幕上绘制一个框架。所以那个Jframe，你知道，无论那个新的Jframe调用字节码变成什么，那个字节码现在需要知道如何在每个操作系统上做到这一点，所以不同的
vms have to know how to do that yeah and so what you end up with with web assembly is you have this pure compute but then if your code needs to access some host function, there are native instructions in the WebAssembly instruction set for sort of asking the host for help to invoke functions on the host. But like I said, it's still entirely up to the host whether or not it's going to allow you to invoke that. And the host chooses how it invokes it as well so what you're starting to see with WebAssembly and these compilers is some of them are building in this this kind of tight coupling between WebAssembly module and the host so with Rust there's this thing called bind gen that allows you to compile things that would normally violate the WebAssembly instruction set, things that wouldn't normally exist. You can compile them in there because it's baking in assumptions bunch of things in that module that assume that the host is a JavaScript runtime.
虚拟机必须知道如何做到这一点。是的，所以你最终在WebAssembly中得到的是这种纯计算。但是，如果你的代码需要访问某些宿主函数，WebAssembly指令集中确实有原生指令，用来请求宿主帮忙调用宿主上的函数。但就像我说的，是否允许你调用，仍然完全由宿主决定。而且宿主也自主选择它如何调用它。所以你开始在WebAssembly和这些编译器中看到的是，其中一些正在内置这种紧密的耦合——WebAssembly模块与宿主之间的耦合。所以在Rust中，有一个叫做bind gen的东西，它允许你编译通常会违反WebAssembly指令集的东西，即通常不存在的东西。你可以将它们编译进去，因为它在那个模块中预设了一堆假设，假定宿主是JavaScript运行时。
And so if you are fine targeting JavaScript as a runtime, like if your goal to use WebAssembly is to just build browser stuff, then things like MindGen can be a huge time saver. If your goal is to run compute in the cloud, on servers, on edge devices, on edge networks, then you can make fewer assumptions about your host. And so you need to bake less and less of that in there. Yeah, that makes sense. I think the WebAssembly thing that, and tell me, you know, if this, if this makes sense, but it sounds like it's just much more productive and much more efficient. Like, I mean, one of the challenges that I had when writing Lambda functions on AWS and Python is you have to, you have to package up the Python. And if you're
因此，如果你以JavaScript作为运行时进行目标定位没有问题——如果你的使用WebAssembly的目标仅仅是构建浏览器端的东西，那么像MindGen这样的工具可以为你节省大量时间。如果你的目标是在云端、服务器上、边缘设备上、边缘网络上运行计算，那么你可以对宿主做出更少的假设。因此，你需要内置的东西就越来越少。是的，这说得通。我觉得WebAssembly这东西，你告诉我，（如果我理解得不对请指正），但听起来它只是生产力更高、效率更高。就像，我在AWS和Python中编写Lambda函数时遇到的挑战之一是，你必须打包Python。如果你
using something like Docker, you have to just constantly be sending Docker images over and you have to worry about layers and, oh, I put my code in the first layer. And so now it's rebuilding the entire image and you put in the other layer. And so a lot of these things just are very complex. And thinking about Java, Java had applets back in the day, and that was also just a total nightmare. You wouldn't really know what functions you could call and what functions you couldn't. I tried to open a TCP connection, and then it's like, oh, no, it would throw a Java runtime exception. And in hindsight, okay, it's obvious you can't make TCP connections from the browser.
使用像Docker这样的工具，你必须不断地发送Docker镜像，你必须担心层（layers）的问题，哦，我把代码放在第一层了，所以现在它在重新构建整个镜像，而你又把它放到了另一层。因此，许多这类事情都非常复杂。想想Java，Java当年有Applet（小程序），那也是一场彻头彻尾的噩梦。你根本不知道你可以调用哪些函数，不能调用哪些函数。我试图打开一个TCP连接，然后它就会抛出一个Java运行时异常。事后看来，好吧，很明显你不能从浏览器发起TCP连接。
But when you're just getting started, there's no guidance. Nothing's really telling you what you can and can't do in all these different environments. And so it became really painful. And then getting people to install the thing so they can run the applet. I mean, all of it was just super painful.
但当你刚开始接触时，没有任何指引。没有什么真正告诉你，在所有这些不同的环境中哪些能做，哪些不能做。所以这变得非常痛苦。而且还要让人安装那个东西以便运行小程序。我的意思是，这一切都超级痛苦。
And it sounds like WebAssembly is building on top of a lot of these things that we've had, but just making it more secure and making it just quicker, faster, less painful. Yeah, I mean, another way to look at WebAssembly is that it's just a secure, portable way to run untrusted code. And so that could apply to anything from building a plugin framework to running pluggable modules in a browser to using it for cloud compute. It's interesting that the fact that its instruction set is so small and it does so little on its own, that that is actually what makes it work in situations
听起来WebAssembly是在我们之前拥有的许多技术的基础之上构建的，但它更安全，而且更快、更敏捷、痛苦更少。是的，换个角度来看WebAssembly，它只是一种运行不受信任的代码的安全、可移植的方式。因此，这可以应用于从构建插件框架到在浏览器中运行可插拔模块，再到将其用于云端计算。有趣的是，它的指令集如此之小、它自身做的事情如此之少，这恰恰是它在那些
where things like Flash and Silverlight and all those other predecessors to it, where those things failed. And I think a lot of the reason why those things fail is those runtimes spread their tentacles out too far and tried to do too much. And so it tightly coupled them to too many things. Yeah, that makes sense.
像Flash、Silverlight以及所有其他前身失败的情况下能够成功的原因。而且我认为这些东西失败的很大一部分原因在于，它们的运行时触角伸得太远，试图做的事情太多了。因此，它们将自身与太多的东西紧密耦合在了一起。是的，这说得通。
Oh, the WebAssembly. So thinking back about the Java applet thing, it was a huge pain to get people to install. I forgot what it was called. Maybe it was just applets, but whatever it was that they could run the applet, right? Basically install the, the Java VM browser extension thing. Right. And so WebAssembly, is that, is that built in or is that, cause I've never seen anything ask me to install WebAssembly. It's just built in.
哦，WebAssembly。回想一下Java Applet那件事，让人们安装它简直是一场巨大的痛苦。我忘了它叫什么名字了，可能就叫applets，但不管怎样，能让它们运行那个东西，基本上就是安装Java虚拟机浏览器扩展程序之类的东西。对吧。那么WebAssembly，这是内置的吗？因为我从来没见过什么东西要求我安装WebAssembly。它就是内置的。
Yeah, it's built in. You don't actually have to install WebAssembly because, at least today, all of the major browsers have WebAssembly support built in. And they all support the JavaScript API for instantiating and executing WebAssembly modules. Got it. And so I have used something for running code in the browser called Emscripten. And what I found is it's really, really hard to debug. Basically, if your code doesn't work, good luck. And even the interop with the browser JavaScript is also really difficult to get right. I know some folks who work at Zynga, who this is their whole life, or at least it used to be. And it's extremely difficult stuff. So does WebAssembly make that
是的，它是内置的。你实际上不需要安装WebAssembly，因为至少在今天，所有主流浏览器都已经内置了对WebAssembly的支持。并且它们都支持用于实例化和执行WebAssembly模块的JavaScript API。明白了。我曾用过一种在浏览器中运行代码的东西，叫Emscripten。我发现它真的非常难调试。基本上，如果你的代码不工作，那就自求多福吧。而且与浏览器JavaScript的互操作也极难搞对。我认识一些在Zynga工作的人，这曾经是他们的全部工作，或者至少过去是。这些东西极其困难。那么WebAssembly会让这些
a lot easier? I mean, if I have a C++, you know, huge library of business logic, and I want to move that onto the browser, and then I want to interact with that business logic from JavaScript code. What's that developer experience like? So I guess it depends on which frameworks you're using and what tool set you're using. So if you're just using just a straight compiler and you're not doing anything fancy or putting any shims or layers on top of that WebAssembly module, then what you're going to get is pure compute. So you'll be able to do math and run calculations and things like that,
变得容易得多吗？我的意思是，如果我有一个C++的大型业务逻辑库，我想把它移到浏览器中，然后我想从JavaScript代码中与该业务逻辑进行交互。那种开发者体验是怎样的？我想这取决于你使用的是哪个框架以及你使用的工具集。如果你只是使用一个纯粹的编译器，不做任何花哨的事情，也没有在那个WebAssembly模块之上添加任何垫片（shims）或层，那么你得到的就是纯计算。所以你将能够做数学运算、运行计算以及类似的事情，
but it won't be able to do anything else. So when you talk about connecting a WebAssembly module to the stuff that it needs in order to do its work, that's when you need to have different hosts. So the browser is one potential host. There are hosts that run inside AWS Lambda. There are hosts that run, like I said, on Cloudflare. And then you also have open source frameworks like WasmCloud, where the developer experience there is you encode your business logic and you interact with your non-functional requirements through abstract contracts. And then the host runtime then takes care of scheduling and running your WebAssembly module and scheduling and running the things that satisfy your non-functional requirements.
但它无法做任何其他事情。所以，当你谈论将WebAssembly模块连接到它完成工作所需的东西时，你就需要有不同的宿主。浏览器就是一个潜在的宿主。有些宿主运行在AWS Lambda内部。有些宿主运行在——正如我所说的——Cloudflare上。然后你还有像WasmCloud这样的开源框架，那里的开发者体验是：你编写业务逻辑，并通过抽象契约与你的非功能性需求进行交互。然后宿主运行时负责调度和运行你的WebAssembly模块，以及调度和运行满足你非功能性需求的组件。
But because of that abstraction and the pluggability of WebAssembly, you can do things like hot swap your business logic without losing messages. You can do things like hot swap your database client without losing messages. So you can, at runtime, literally switch from Redis to Cassandra without your actual business logic being aware of that change. You can move your compute closer to the source of the data that you're computing against, which, you know, does, you know, that enables models like being able to do sensor aggregation inside a car without having to ship data off of the vehicle. Things like machine learning models where you want the compute to run closer to the stream of data.
但由于这种抽象和WebAssembly的可插拔性，你可以做到诸如热插拔业务逻辑而不会丢失消息。你可以做到诸如热插拔数据库客户端而不会丢失消息。因此，你可以在运行时字面意义上从Redis切换到Cassandra，而你的实际业务逻辑甚至不需要感知到这种变化。你可以将计算迁移到更靠近你正在计算的数据源的地方，你知道，这启用了诸如在汽车内部进行传感器聚合而无需将数据运出车辆的模型。像机器学习模型，你希望计算在更靠近数据流的地方运行。
So all of those types of scenarios are just made easier when your business logic is this tiny little thing that can run anywhere. You know, it enables a ton of extra scenarios that were just not really all not really possible or practical without technology like WebAssembly. Yeah, that makes sense. So so let's let's try and like dive into the example here. So let's say I don't know what you'd call it, like, I guess a service. I have I have something running in WebAssembly and, you know, I want to send, you know, JSON, you know, objects to that to talk to it, like an RPC type thing. So I want to send JSON objects to it. It's, you know, it'll do some machine learning or something like that, and it'll come back with a JSON response.
所以，当你的业务逻辑是一个可以在任何地方运行的微小事物时，所有这些场景都变得更容易了。你知道，它开启了大量如果没有像WebAssembly这样的技术就真的不可能或不切实际的额外场景。是的，这说得通。所以，让我们试着深入探讨一下这里的例子。假设——我不知道你该怎么称呼它——比如一个服务。我有一些在WebAssembly中运行的东西，你知道，我想向它发送JSON对象来与其对话，就像RPC类型的东西一样。所以我想向它发送JSON对象。它会进行一些机器学习或类似的事情，然后返回一个JSON响应。
And so if I want to do that, you know, let's say we want to do that on the browser and on the desktop. What does that look like? I guess you said something about contracts. Is there some sort of contract you define that says this is almost like... I'm thinking about Swagger here, like OpenAPI. It says this is the JSON I expect, and then this is the JSON you're going to get back. And is it something like that so again it's it's interesting it's important to to keep in mind where webassembly stops and then the layers that other people have built on top of it begin so you can't do what you just described
所以如果我想这样做，比如说我们想在浏览器和桌面上都这样做。这会是什么样的？我想你之前提到过关于契约的事情。是否存在某种你定义的契约，说明这几乎就像……我在这里想到的是Swagger，比如OpenAPI。它说这是我期望的JSON，然后这是你将获得的JSON返回。它是那样东西吗？所以——同样地，保持清醒很重要——记住WebAssembly在何处停止，以及其他人构建在其之上的层在何处开始。你无法用纯粹的WebAssembly做到你刚才描述的事情，
with a straight up webassembly because you, you can't send a WebAssembly module arbitrary blobs of data, let alone JSON that it can interpret and send back to you. So like I said, there's that path where, you know, people start at the core of what WebAssembly can do, and then they start figuring out the things that they need to add to WebAssembly in order to do things that they're trying to do. So the first thing you need to do is figure out how to get complex data in and out of a WebAssembly module. There are some standards that aren't really, they're not fully baked into all the engines yet that will help with that. So today, you basically have to either come up with your own or use a framework that lets you do that.
因为你不能向WebAssembly模块发送任意的二进制数据块（blobs），更不用说能让它解释并传回给你的JSON了。所以就像我说的，有一条那样的路径：人们从WebAssembly核心能做的事情开始，然后开始摸索他们需要向WebAssembly添加什么东西，以便做他们试图去做的事情。所以你需要做的第一件事是弄清楚如何将复杂的数据传入和传出WebAssembly模块。有一些标准还没有完全融入所有的引擎中来帮助解决这个问题。所以今天，你基本上必须要么想出你自己的方法，要么使用一个允许你这样做的框架。
Microsoft, they built an open source tool called Waggy, which lets you build WebAssembly modules that run as a CGI interface. So you can build little tiny web servers with them. But like I said, the things, once you get past that, that isolated sandbox of WebAssembly, everything you're doing beyond that use frameworks and runtimes. And so you just sort of have to pick which Lego blocks you want to use in order to build what you want. So the scenario you described where, you know, you've got some business logic that you built and you want it to run on a desktop
微软构建了一个名为Waggy的开源工具，它允许你构建作为CGI接口运行的WebAssembly模块。所以你可以用它们构建微型网络服务器。但就像我说的，一旦你越过了WebAssembly那个孤立的沙箱，你在那之后所做的一切都是在使用框架和运行时。所以你只需要挑选你想使用哪些积木来构建你想要的东西。所以你描述的场景——你知道，你构建了一些业务逻辑，并且你希望它在桌面上运行，
and you want it to run in a cloud and you want to be able to send it some JSON and get some JSON back. That's exactly what frameworks like WasmCloud do. And you know, there are others out there as well that'll enable that scenario in one way or another. Got it. So to contrast this with Python, so with Python, you have a interop library that's built into the, and this is stretching, really stretching the bounds of what I know, but built into like the VM slash language of it. And so if I, for example, want to, you know, call a Python module from C++, then I could actually use the Python C++, you know, the binding to go in and
并且你希望它在云端运行，并且你希望能够向它发送一些JSON并取回一些JSON。这正是像WasmCloud这样的框架所做的事情。你知道，还有其他的框架也可以以这样或那样的方式实现这一场景。明白了。所以为了与Python形成对比，在Python中，有一个内置在——这里有点勉强，大大超出了我了解的范围——内置在虚拟机/语言之中的互操作库。所以如果我例如想要从C++中调用一个Python模块，我实际上可以使用Python的C++绑定去
call Python. So all of it is sort of built in. You're saying for WebAssembly, it's like, no, you need a module that would sort of define, maybe that module has C++ headers and then also has something on the... Actually, yeah. So I have to think about that. So the module would somehow have to... So your WebAssembly program could have been anything. It could have been Java or Python or C++ or whatever, but it needs a way to talk to that module, which then has an interface in C++. Did I get that right? Yeah. So there's a number
调用Python。所以所有这些都是内置的。你是说对于WebAssembly，情况是这样的：不，你需要一个模块来定义它，也许该模块有C++头文件，然后在……实际上，是的。我得考虑一下这一点。所以该模块必须以某种方式……因此，你的WebAssembly程序可能是任何东西。它可以是Java、Python、C++或任何语言，但它需要一种方法来与该模块对话，而该模块随后在C++中有一个接口。我理解得对吗？是的。所以有许多
of things going on there. And I didn't mention it earlier, but when you build a WebAssembly function, the only parameters that it can receive or return are numbers. There's no other data type inside WebAssembly other than numbers. And so, like I said, there are limitations in there that need to be overcome somehow. There's standards like interface types, which are going to help translate the data that you are working on in a way that's native to you. So if you're in your C++ code, or if you're in your Rust code or whatever, and then you want to call a function that's been built in a WebAssembly module, there'll be a translation layer there that will sort of get that job done. If you want to do more than that, WebAssembly has these, you know, what are called imports and exports. And that's
在那里发生的事情。我刚才没提到，但当你构建一个 WebAssembly 函数时，它能接收或返回的唯一参数就是数字。WebAssembly 内部除了数字之外没有其他数据类型。所以就像我说的，那里的限制需要通过某种方式来克服。有一些像接口类型这样的标准，它们将帮助你以对你来说是原生（native）的方式来转换你正在处理的数据。因此，如果你在用 C++ 代码，或者你在用 Rust 代码等等，然后你想调用一个在 WebAssembly 模块中构建的函数，那里就会有一个转换层来把这件事情搞定。如果你想做更多的事情，WebAssembly 还有这些，你知道的，被称为导入和导出（imports and exports）的东西。这就是
where you get that sort of interop layer. So in Python and in other languages, you have this thing called FFI or the foreign function interface. And that is a standard that languages use in order to talk to one another from one another. And something similar has to happen with WebAssembly. So you need an import and an export in order to have that communication in and out of the module. But again, those imports and exports can only deal with numbers. your high-level data, your arrays, your structs, blobs, and things like that into just numbers.
你获得那种互操作层（interop layer）的地方。所以在 Python 和其他语言中，你有这样一个东西叫做 FFI 或外部函数接口（foreign function interface）。那是语言用来彼此互相沟通的标准。WebAssembly 也必须发生类似的事情。所以你需要一个导入和一个导出，以便在该模块内部和外部进行这种通信。但同样地，这些导入和导出只能处理数字。你的高级数据、你的数组、你的结构体、二进制大对象（blobs）以及诸如此类的东西。
Today's sponsor is Rollbar. Rollbar is the leading platform that enables developers to proactively discover and resolve issues in their code, allowing them to work on continuous code improvement throughout the software development lifecycle. Rollbar has plans for all situations, from free to large enterprise. With Rollbar, developers deploy better software faster and can quickly recover from critical errors as they happen.
今天的赞助商是 Rollbar。Rollbar 是领先的平台，使开发人员能够主动发现和解决代码中的问题，让他们能够在整个软件开发生命周期中致力于持续改进代码。Rollbar 为各种情况制定了计划，从免费版到大型企业版。通过 Rollbar，开发人员可以更快地部署更好的软件，并能在关键错误发生时迅速从错误中恢复。
We have a special URL at https://try.rollbar.com.pt for programming throwdown. There you can find two free ebooks, How Debugging is Changing and How Dev Experience Matters, as well as sign up for a free Got it. So you're building a program in Rust and you target WebAssembly and your Rust program provides some kind of interface, as you said, an FFI, or maybe it's running a web service or something like that. And so I guess as part of compiling it to WebAssembly, you need to provide, I think, modules, right? You have to provide modules that can fill in some of those gaps. So when you compile your WebAssembly module in Rust, you're compiling some subset of Rust that can be converted into WebAssembly bytecode without invoking functions that don't exist. So you can't just take Rust and compile a web server
我们在 https://try.rollbar.com.pt/for-programming-throwdown 为大家准备了一个特殊的网址。在那里你可以找到两本免费电子书：《调试方式的改变》（How Debugging is Changing）和《开发体验的重要性》（How Dev Experience Matters），还可以注册免费账号。明白了。所以你正在用 Rust 构建一个程序，然后你将其目标设为 WebAssembly，你的 Rust 程序提供某种接口，正如你所说的一个 FFI，或者可能它在运行一个 Web 服务或类似的东西。所以我想作为将其编译为 WebAssembly 的一部分，你需要提供，我认为，就是模块，对吧？你必须提供能够填补其中一些空白的模块。因此，当你在 Rust 中编译你的 WebAssembly 模块时，你编译的是 Rust 的某个子集，它可以被转换为 WebAssembly 字节码，而不会调用不存在的函数。所以你不能只是拿一段 Rust 代码然后编译一个 Web 服务器，
and then think it's going to work in WebAssembly. You can get closer if you use WASI, which is the system interface on top of regular WebAssembly, and that's also kind of smoke and mirrors because Wazi is really just a set of imports that a host needs to provide to give a module access to low-level operating system type stuff. So even when you're just compiling the simplest of things, some of that stuff just isn't going to work out of the box. And so, you know, the imports and exports, those are all runtime. They are not compiled into a WebAssembly module. So, you know, the WebAssembly module expects its host to provide all of its dependencies at runtime through imports. And how the hosts and the guest module communicate with each other is entirely up to the host
然后就认为它能在 WebAssembly 中工作。如果你使用 WASI，也就是常规 WebAssembly 之上的系统接口，你可以更接近这个目标，这也是一种障眼法，因为 Wazi 实际上只是一组主机需要提供给模块的导入，以便让模块访问底层操作系统类型的东西。所以，即使你在编译最简单的事情时，其中一些东西也无法直接开箱即用。所以，你知道的，导入和导出，这些全都是运行时的。它们没有被编译到 WebAssembly 模块中。所以，你知道的，WebAssembly 模块期望它的主机在运行时通过导入提供它的所有依赖项。而主机和客体模块（guest module）如何相互通信完全取决于主机
and the guest module. And so there's this gap there where we don't really have any high-level standards for how hosts communicate with guest modules. So people are building them. You've got WASI, which is your system-level interface. You have interfaces that frameworks like WasmCloud build. So there's an interface for a web server. There's an interface for a database client.
和客体模块。所以这里有一个鸿沟，我们对于主机如何与客体模块通信并没有任何高级标准。因此人们正在构建它们。你有 WASI，它是你的系统级接口。你有像 WasmCloud 这样的框架构建的接口。所以有一个针对 Web 服务器的接口。有一个针对数据库客户端的接口。
There's an interface for Telnet even. There's an interface for a database client. There's an interface for Telnet even. There's an interface for a message broker. But that agreed upon contract between the host and the guest, that's something that both sides of that half need to agree on. So you can use compiler tricks and macros and code generators like BindGen to take care of generating code on both sides of that line so that they build that contract for you and you don't really have to know it's there. Like I said, if you're using Rust to build code that you know is only going to run in a browser,
甚至还有一个用于 Telnet 的接口。有一个针对数据库客户端的接口。甚至还有一个用于 Telnet 的接口。有一个针对消息代理的接口。但是主机和客体之间达成一致的契约，那是那一半的两端都需要达成一致的东西。所以你可以使用编译器技巧、宏以及像 BindGen 这样的代码生成器来负责在那条线的两侧生成代码，这样它们就能为你构建该契约，而你实际上不必知道它就在那里。就像我说的，如果你使用 Rust 构建你知道只会运行在浏览器中的代码，
there's tons of stuff that you can do to make your life easier to pretend that WebAssembly isn't as low level as it is. You know, you can make it look like you can allocate a JavaScript object that's actually an object inside your WebAssembly module, but that's all just generated code and shims and wrappers doing that for you. When people start looking at WebAssembly, the first thing they see is all this JavaScript stuff. And so they just assume that WebAssembly is responsible for all of this power. When what's really driving some of the really impressive scenarios is the clever
你可以做大量的事情来让你的生活更轻松，假装 WebAssembly 并没有那么底层。你知道的，你可以让它看起来像你可以分配一个 JavaScript 对象，它实际上是你的 WebAssembly 模块内部的一个对象，但这全都是为你做这件事的生成代码、垫片（shims）和包装器（wrappers）。当人们开始研究 WebAssembly 时，他们首先看到的就是所有这些 JavaScript 的东西。所以他们只是假设 WebAssembly 对所有这些功能负有责任。而真正推动一些非常令人印象深刻的场景的，其实是人们在 WebAssembly 模块之上放置的那些巧妙的
wrappers and shims and layers that people are putting on top of the WebAssembly modules in order for them to do these powerful things. Got it. Got it. So I think, I mean, I remember in this, this might be a while ago, but someone used WebAssembly to get, I think it was Doom or Quake or one of these games running in the browser. And so if we dive into that, you know, if you're making, let's say Doom, you know, you have making let's say doom you know you have logic you say when i walk forward you know my character x coordinate y coordinate changes like this and here's you know the how often you know like i'm going to update my game tick and my imp throws a fireball and all these things um and all these functions if you if you drill down if you were to sort of really
包装器、垫片和层，以便让它们能够做这些强大的事情。明白了。明白了。所以我想，我的意思是，我记得在这个，这可能是一段时间以前了，但有人使用 WebAssembly 让，我想是《毁灭战士》（Doom）或《雷神之锤》（Quake）或者其中一个游戏在浏览器中运行。所以如果我们深入探讨这个，你知道，如果你在制作，比方说《毁灭战士》，你知道，你有制作比方说《毁灭战士》你知道你有逻辑你说当我向前走你知道我的角色 x 坐标 y 坐标像这样变化然后这里是你知道的频率你知道就像我要更新我的游戏 tick（游戏时钟周期）然后我的小鬼（imp）扔出一个火球以及所有这些东西，嗯，所有这些函数如果你，如果你深入挖掘，如果你真的
drill down or even you could do this in any program out there you're writing right now, if you call list.sort or something like that in, let's say, C++, that function is also going to be written in C++, right? And that function is going to be made of other C++. But eventually you get down to the point where you're either doing something really fundamental like arithmetic um or you're making you're making calls that um that that are that are in in sort of assembly or really really low level and so some of these calls like um um like open a network connection you know at some
深入挖掘，或者你甚至可以在你现在正在编写的任何程序中做到这一点，如果你在比方说 C++ 中调用 list.sort 或类似的东西，那个函数也将是用 C++ 编写的，对吧？那个函数将由其他 C++ 组成。但最终你会深入到这样一个地步：你要么在做一些非常基础的事情，比如算术，嗯，要嘛你在进行一些调用，嗯，这些调用，嗯，是用，用汇编语言或者非常非常底层的东西编写的。所以其中一些调用，比如，嗯，比如打开一个网络连接，你知道，在某个
point you're not in c++ land anymore you're going and like telling the kernel to give me a network connection. And so that is that sort of import. You're like, you're importing that function into the C++ language. And so you're saying, between this negotiate with guests and hosts, you say, well, this host and I have agreed that you have the open TCP connection, open TCP connection, you know, function that
时间点你不再处于 C++ 领域了，你要去告诉内核给我一个网络连接。所以这就是那种导入。你就像是在把那个函数导入到 C++ 语言中。所以你在说，在与客体和主机进行这种协商时，你说，好吧，这个主机和我已经同意了，你拥有打开 TCP 连接，打开 TCP 连接，你知道，这个函数
was super low level. And so when you go to compile your code, you know, you either have that or you don't. And so do you know that at compile time or, you know, if you compile on your desktop and run on the browser, could you be in a situation where the function actually doesn't exist anymore? Yeah. So what you're describing is part of it is, you know, what in compiler terms is called linking. So when you compile all the way down to sort of the lowest level primitives,
是超级底层的。所以当你去编译你的代码时，你知道，你要么拥有它，要么没有。所以你是在编译时就知道这一点，还是说，如果你在桌面上编译并在浏览器中运行，你是否可能会处于这样一种情况：该函数实际上已经不存在了？是的。所以你所描述的是，其中一部分是，你知道，在编译器术语中称为什么链接（linking）。因此，当你一直编译到某种最底层的原语时，
at some point, one of those primitives is going to need to access some function that isn't inside your code that is either you know it's like inside a kernel or it's inside a host or it's it's somewhere that your code can't find it so it needs to cross that boundary somehow and a linker will embed the desk the target of your function call into the thing that you're building. So you get like an executable or something like that. What happens with WebAssembly is when you're compiling these things, sometimes the compilers are clever enough to replace the call that goes across a traditional link boundary with something like executing a WebAssembly import function. But what happens is because it's replaced those functions,
在某个时间点，这些原语中的一个将需要访问某个不在你的代码中的函数，这个函数要么，你知道的，它就像在内核内部，或者它在主机内部，或者它在你的代码找不到的某个地方，所以它需要以某种方式跨越那个边界，而链接器会将你的函数调用的目标嵌入到你正在构建的东西中。所以你会得到一个可执行文件或类似的东西。WebAssembly 发生的情况是，当你编译这些东西时，有时编译器足够聪明，可以用诸如执行 WebAssembly 导入函数之类的事情来替换跨越传统链接边界的调用。但发生的情况是，因为它替换了那些函数，
instead of being able to link the real implementation of it at compile time, you now have the reliance on the host to have that function for you at runtime. There are things you can do where you can, you know, you can read the WebAssembly module to get a list of the functions that it imports and see if you're ready to provide them all. So you can, you know, kind of pre-validate that. But like with the Doom example, you know, you'll compile this core nugget into a WebAssembly module. And then I haven't seen the code for this, but one way to do WebAssembly module to generate the applicable content for that frame.
它没有在编译时链接它的真实实现，而是依赖于主机在运行时为你准备好那个函数。你可以做一些事情，比如你可以，你知道的，你可以读取 WebAssembly 模块来获取它导入的函数列表，并查看你是否准备好提供所有这些函数。所以你可以，你知道的，进行某种预验证。但就像《毁灭战士》的那个例子，你知道的，你会把这个核心片段编译成一个 WebAssembly 模块。然后我没看过这段代码，但制作 WebAssembly 模块的一种方法是为该帧生成适用的内容。
And inside the Doom code, there were functions that used to render directly to a video card that now ask the host to render maybe through some abstraction. And then the JavaScript host has functions that satisfy those imports. And instead of rendering to a video card, now render to a canvas. And things like OpenGL type support in a JavaScript library make those kinds of translations super easy. So with a combination of shims, wrappers,
在《毁灭战士》的代码内部，有一些过去直接渲染到显卡的函数，现在它们要求主机可能通过某种抽象来进行渲染。然后 JavaScript 主机拥有满足这些导入的函数。它们不再渲染到显卡，而是渲染到画布（canvas）上。诸如 JavaScript 库中的 OpenGL 类型支持之类的事情使得这类转换变得超级简单。因此，通过结合垫片、包装器，
and very smart compilers, you can do things like distill Doom down to its core calculations and then externalize the rendering into something that javascript does and that pattern of putting the pure business logic and you know for doom the pure business logic is you know calculating damage and location and range and who's where and where the projectiles are and things like that and then converting that into a static image of what one frame looks like
以及非常聪明的编译器，你可以做一些事情，比如将《毁灭战士》提炼为其核心计算，然后将渲染外包给 JavaScript 所做的事情，以及将纯粹的业务逻辑放置在那里的模式，你知道，对于《毁灭战士》来说，纯粹的业务逻辑是，你知道，计算伤害、位置、范围、谁在哪里、发射物在哪里等等，然后将其转换为一个静态图像，展示单帧的外观，
but then the external function that isn't in the WebAssembly module that's the responsibility of the host is you know rendering that bitmap onto you onto a canvas inside your browser. And where the portability power of that comes from is, let's say that that function interface for rendering things like a frame buffer, let's say that that was a standard that many different hosts supported. So now you can then take this tiny DOOM WebAssembly module and run it anywhere that can supply it
但是不在 WebAssembly 模块中的外部函数——那是主机的责任——你知道的，就是在你的浏览器内部将该位图渲染到画布上。而这带来的可移植性能力的来源在于，比方说，用于渲染诸如帧缓冲区（frame buffer）之类东西的那个函数接口，比方说那是一个许多不同主机都支持的标准。所以现在你就可以拿这个微小的《毁灭战士》WebAssembly 模块，并在任何能够为它提供
with a renderable frame buffer. And so this is where you start to see some of the promise of what WebAssembly is going to look like in the future when tooling makes a lot of this stuff easier or automatic. So you now just have these bits of compute that run anywhere you want them to, at any scale you want them to, as far or as close to their data sources as you want them to that can consume portable services that may act differently. Like another scenario that I love, and I've done a number of times with WebAssembly,
可渲染帧缓冲区的运行环境上运行它。因此，这就是你开始看到 WebAssembly 在未来会是什么样子的某些前景的地方，当工具让这一切变得更轻松或自动化时。所以你现在只需拥有这些计算片段，它们可以如你所愿地在任何地方运行，以你所愿的任何规模运行，只要你愿意，它们可以离其数据源多近或多远，它们可以消费可能表现不同的可移植服务。就像我喜欢的另一个场景一样，我用 WebAssembly 做过好多次，
is you have a WebAssembly module that has a contract for turning on or off the voltage in wires. So let's say you have five wires and on those five wires, that contract can say, you know, that, that pin is either up or down. And so when you have, you can put logic in a, in a web assembly module that controls the abstraction of those pins. And then,
你有一个 WebAssembly 模块，它具有一个用于打开或关闭电线中电压的契约。比方说你有五根电线，在这五根电线上，该契约可以说明，你知道，那个，那个引脚是高电平还是低电平。所以当你拥有时，你可以将逻辑放在一个 WebAssembly 模块中，该模块控制这些引脚的抽象。然后，
so when you run that module on a Raspberry Pi, you could be controlling, you know, a big bank of LEDs where you're setting the color and you're setting, you know, which ones are on, which ones are off. You can make all sorts of patterns. You could use it for like an alert indicator for different conditions but you could also take that same module out of the raspberry pi put it on your laptop and run simulations and tests because you have this abstraction now you could then also take
当你将该模块在树莓派（Raspberry Pi）上运行构建时，你可能在控制，你知道的，一大排 LED 灯，你在其中设置颜色，你还在设置，你知道的，哪些亮，哪些灭。你可以制作各种各样的模式。你可以将其用于诸如针对不同条件的警报指示器，但你也可以把同一个模块从树莓派中拿出来，放到你的笔记本电脑上运行模拟和测试，因为你现在有了这个抽象，你随后还可以
that same module stick it in a browser and then then, you know, when the module says, you know, I want, you know, LED one to be red, you can just turn a box somewhere in the browser on and color it red. Cool. That makes sense. Actually. So, okay. Now I think it's really starting to come together, together for us. So, okay. One thing I'm trying to wrap my head around. So I think WebAssembly, we've, we've, I think got it nailed down thing I'm trying to wrap my head around. So I think WebAssembly, we've, I think, got it nailed down. I'm trying to wrap my head around Wasm Cloud now. So you talked about, you're talking to a database and some of those things. It feels like, I'm not totally grokking why Wasm Cloud would be at that level of talking to a database and not at like a much
将同一个模块塞进浏览器中，然后，你知道的，当模块说，你知道的，我想要，你知道的，LED 1 变成红色时，你只需打开浏览器中的某个方框并将其涂成红色。酷。这说得通。实际上。所以，好吧。现在我想它真的开始对我们来说融会贯通了。所以，好吧。我正在努力理解的一件事。所以我想 WebAssembly，我们已经，我想已经掌握了。我正在努力理解 Wasm Cloud。所以你谈到了，你正在与数据库对话以及其中的一些事情。感觉就像是，我并不是完全理解为什么 Wasm Cloud 会处于与数据库对话的那种级别，而不是处于诸如 TCP 套接字或类似东西的那种更加
lower level of, you know, like a TCP socket or something like that. So how does, like, why is assembly kind of like going up the scale there and how is that useful? Sure. So if you think about, you know, what the daily experience is like when you build microservices, think about somebody says you need to build this microservice that does a handful of things. And what you end up with is you copy in the boilerplate for starting a web server. Then you paste in the boilerplate for configuring the routes. Then you paste in some more boilerplate for consuming a database client, and that database client is tightly coupled. So, you know, you might have a Postgres client library in there
底层的级别。所以，为什么汇编有点像是在那里提升了规模，这有什么用呢？当然。所以如果你想想，你知道的，当你构建微服务时的日常体验是什么样的，想想有人说你需要构建这个能够处理几件事情的微服务。而你最终得到的是，你复制了启动 Web 服务器的样板代码（boilerplate）。然后你粘贴了用于配置路由的样板代码。然后你粘贴了更多用于消费数据库客户端的样板代码，并且那个数据库客户端是紧密耦合的。所以，你知道的，你可能在那里有一个 Postgres 客户端库
or something like that. Somewhere in that giant pile of boilerplate is like 10 lines of business logic. And then when you deploy, you're deploying that 10 lines of business logic bolted and duct taped onto all of those other things that you just jammed into that module. There's a reason why a Hello World microservice in Java can consume a one gig container. So what we wanted to do was separate those five lines of business logic from all the other non-functional requirements that are crammed into your typical microservice. And so a runtime like WasmCloud sits above the WebAssembly engine level.
或类似的东西。在那堆巨大的样板代码中的某处，大约有 10 行业务逻辑。然后当你部署时，你部署的是那 10 行用螺栓固定并通过胶带粘在刚才塞进那个模块的所有其他东西上的业务逻辑。Java 中的一个 Hello World 微服务可以吃掉一个 1G 的容器，这是有原因的。所以我们想要做的是将这五行业务逻辑与塞进你典型微服务中的所有其他非功能性需求分开。因此，像 WasmCloud 这样的运行时位于 WebAssembly 引擎级别之上。
And it provides, like I said, that mutually agreed upon contract between the host and the module. So with WasmCloud, there are a number of different contracts. So there's a contract for receiving messages from a web server. There's a contract for interacting with a message broker. There's one for talking to a SQL database. You can make your own contracts, in which case you can also make your own capability providers. So you can add as many abstractions as you want
并且它提供了，正如我所说的，主机和模块之间双向达成一致的契约。所以在 WasmCloud 中，有许多不同的契约。所以有一个用于接收来自 Web 服务器的消息的契约。有一个用于与消息代理交互的契约。还有一个用于与 SQL 数据库对话的契约。你可以制作自己的契约，在这种情况下，你还可以制作自己的能力提供程序（capability providers）。因此你可以根据需要向
to the Wasm Cloud ecosystem. And what you build as the developer is an actor. We follow the actor pattern, but it's a little WebAssembly module. And the units of deployment that we have are, you know, from the biggest language target at around 1.5 megs down to 64k. So if you think about going from deploying one gig mammoths to do a small amount of work to deploying these tiny little things to do the same amount of work in a more portable, more loosely coupled way, then we start gaining all sorts of advantages
Wasm Cloud 生态系统添加任意多的抽象。而作为开发人员，你构建的是一个参与者（actor）。我们遵循参与者模式（actor pattern），但它是一个小小的 WebAssembly 模块。我们拥有的部署单元是，你知道的，从最大语言目标的约 1.5MB 一直到 64K。所以如果你想想从部署一头吞噬巨量资源的庞然大物来做少量工作，转变为部署这些微小的东西来以一种更便携、更松耦合的方式完成同样的工作，那么我们开始获得各种各样的优势，
that we didn't have before. So now that we can write business logic that consumes these contracts, we know that the thing that fulfills that contract can change. And so that same scenario where in one situation, your code is controlling real hardware and another situation, your code is in a simulator, that also applies to going from dev to prod, right? When you build your hello world code in the regular microservices way, you get your hello world code working and it's fantastic. And then when you have to go take it on that pipeline to running in production, chances
这是我们以前没有的。所以现在我们可以编写消费这些契约的业务逻辑，我们知道履行该契约的东西是可以改变的。因此，在一种情况下，你的代码控制真实的硬件，而在另一种情况下，你的代码在一个模拟器中，同样的场景也适用于从开发环境到生产环境的过渡，对吧？当你以常规微服务的方式构建你的 Hello World 代码时，你让你的 Hello World 代码工作起来了，这太棒了。然后当你不得不把它带上那个在生产环境中运行的流水线时，很有可能
are you're going to have to rip out three quarters of that boilerplate because your local environment test doesn't match all of the cloud tentacles that your code needs to run in when you deploy it to AWS or Google or wherever. But with that abstraction, you can use an in-memory database when you're developing on your workstation. And then when you push the same code without ever recompiling it, the same sealed cryptographically signed unit of compute out to production, the production version of that environment can supply a Postgres database
你将不得不拆掉其中四分之三的样板代码，因为你的本地环境测试与你的代码在部署到 AWS、谷歌或其他任何地方时需要运行的所有云端触角并不匹配。但有了这种抽象，当你在工作站上开发时，你可以使用内存数据库。然后当你推送相同的代码（无需重新编译它，即相同的加盖了密码学签名的计算单元）到生产环境中时，该环境的生产版本可以提供一个 Postgres 数据库
or Cassandra or Redis or whatever. And the logic that you wrote doesn't change. Got it. So let me unpack this. So, for example, if you were trying to spin up a web service and i'll stick with python because that's the one i know the best but if you're trying to spin up a web service now you would get a you know a fast api server you'd write as you said a bunch of boilerplate for different routes and then and then you would use something like sql alchemy
或者 Cassandra 或 Redis 等等。而你编写的逻辑不会改变。明白了。所以让我来剖析一下。所以，例如，如果你试图启动一个 Web服务，我将坚持使用 Python，因为那是我最熟悉的，但如果你现在试图启动一个 Web服务，你会得到一个，你知道的，FastAPI 服务器，你会写，正如你所说的，一堆用于不同路由的样板代码，然后，然后你会使用诸如 SQL Alchemy 之类的东西，
which has clients for it's basically a multiplexer for all these different clients. And so you can tell SQL Alchemy, you know, I want to access this SQLite database for development. And, you know, you can, you know, run locally. And then you have some config somewhere that's saying, okay, when I'm in the cloud, MySQL Alchemy connects to Postgres and when I'm local, it connects to this SQLite that's on my laptop. And so the issue there is that SQL Alchemy has to do a lot of heavy lifting
它有客户端，它基本上是所有这些不同客户端的多路复用器（multiplexer）。所以你可以告诉 SQL Alchemy，你知道的，我想要访问这个 SQLite 数据库用于开发。而且，你知道的，你可以，你知道的，在本地运行。然后你在某处有一些配置，上面写着，好吧，当我在云端时，MySQL Alchemy 连接到 Postgres，而当我在本地时，它连接到我笔记本电脑上的这个 SQLite。所以这里的问题是 SQL Alchemy 必须做很多繁重的工作，
and it also has to know about every single database. And then I have to get really clever about, when I pip install it, I have to pip install just the databases I want, or I end up with this massive binary and it all kind of blows up. And then also I'm really relying on SQL Alchemy to use that language.
而且它还必须了解每一个数据库。然后我必须变得非常聪明，当我执行 pip install 时，我必须仅 pip install 我想要的数据库，或者我最终会得到这个巨大的二进制文件，它基本上全都炸掉了。然后我也确实非常依赖 SQL Alchemy 来使用该语言。
I'm sort of like expecting a contract from SQL Alchemy that if I call my ORM, if I call my object relational mapper functions, that they're going to do exactly the same thing for every database. And there's just a ton of work that goes into on there and that goes into that. And that work translates into a large binary. And so you're saying Wasm Cloud is trying to move that problem across the, I guess, the VM boundary. And so you can imagine now like Cloudflare has an implementation of a Postgres client and a SQLite client in it. And so now you don't have, you know, my binary running SQL Alchemy and your binary running SQL Alchemy and Patrick's binary running SQL Alchemy all in the same cloud,
我有点像是在期待来自 SQL Alchemy 的一个契约，即如果我调用我的 ORM，如果我调用我的对象关系映射器（object relational mapper）函数，它们将为每个数据库做完全相同的事情。而且那里投入了大量的功力和投入。而这项工作转化为一个大型二进制文件。所以你的意思是 Wasm Cloud 正在试图将该问题跨越，我猜是虚拟机（VM）边界进行移动。所以你现在可以想象，就像 Cloudflare 在其中实现了一个 Postgres 客户端和一个 SQLite 客户端。所以现在你不会拥有，你知道的，我的运行 SQL Alchemy 的二进制文件和你运行 SQL Alchemy 的二进制文件的以及帕特里克的运行 SQL Alchemy 的二进制文件全都运行在同一个云中，
running different versions. My version hasn't been patched yet and has an exploit, et cetera, et cetera. Like you could move that to, you know, Cloudflare, for example, and that makes our binaries small, you know, and makes their load also smaller. Yeah, that's a really good point. And, you know, it's one of the things that, you know, not everybody sort of sees on first glance when you look at what WasmCloud does. So, you know, decoupling things is just sort of part of the picture. But the way that it gets decoupled is also saving you a lot of time and effort as well. So like you said, you could have, let's say you have a web server and you're a huge enterprise,
运行着不同的版本。我的版本还没有打补丁，存在漏洞，等等，等等。就像你可以把它移到，你知道的，Cloudflare，例如，这使得我们的二进制文件很小，你知道的，并且也使得它们的负载更小。是的，这是一个非常好的观点。而且，你知道的，这是你在初看 WasmCloud 的作用时，并不是每个人都能注意到的事情之一。所以，你知道的，解耦事情只是画面的一部分。但它被解耦的方式也为你节省了大量的时间和精力。所以就像你说的，你可以拥有，比方说你有一个 Web 服务器，而你是一个巨大的企业，
you've got a web server that everybody has been using, it's a Java dependency, and all of a sudden someone publishes a vulnerability saying that you need to immediately upgrade all of these web servers from this version to some other version. You now have this entire enterprise that has to stop all of its current work and have each one of those dev teams that has taken that dependency, then blow a sprint or more, upgrading their code to the newest version, and then repackaging, redeploying, recertifying, retesting, all of that stuff. Those pipelines to go from a minor code change to production, while we would love those to be, you know, an hour, they're certainly not. And in many cases, it can take weeks worth of paperwork or, you know, bureaucracy to get your code from fixed to deployed in production. But if you have something, a framework that has decoupled those things for you, like WasmCloud, then what you can do is while your code is running, while your business logic is still actively running,
你有一个每个人都在使用的 Web 服务器，它是一个 Java 依赖项，突然之间有人发布了一个漏洞，称你需要立即将所有这些 Web 服务器从这个版本升级到其他某个版本。你现在拥有了整个企业，它必须停止当前所有的工作，并且让采用该依赖项的每个开发团队，然后浪费一个或多个冲刺（sprint）的时间，将他们的代码升级到最新版本，然后重新打包、重新部署、重新认证、重新测试，所有这些事情。那些让代码从微小改动到在生产环境中运行的流水线，虽然我们希望它们是，你知道的，一个小时，但它们绝对不是。并且在许多情况下，可能需要数周的文书工作或，你知道的，官僚主义才能让你的代码从修复到在生产环境中部署。但如果你拥有某种框架，它为你解耦了这些东西，比如 WasmCloud，那么你能做的是，当你的代码正在运行，当你的业务逻辑仍然在云中活跃地运行、
deployed and scaled in a cloud, you can live patch the web server from one version to the other and you do it once and uh the problem is is no longer an issue and and it's because those modules are no longer tightly coupled to those dependencies there's there's a saying that like when you build these microservices you own your dependencies and that's not really the case anymore with something that gives you this level of abstraction yeah that is really really cool um i mean i i you see examples of this pattern you know like i know a lot of loggers have different back ends and so you swap out the back end you get different functionality with the same api um or you're thinking of sdl like going back to doom example you know someone someone ported doom to sit on top of sdl and so now um sdl has a million different different back ends
部署和缩放时，你可以热修补（live patch）Web服务器，从一个版本到另一个版本，你只需要做一次，呃，问题就不再是一个问题了，这正是因为这些模块不再与那些依赖项紧密耦合。有一句俗语说，当你构建这些微服务时，你要对自己的依赖项负责，而对于提供这种抽象级别的系统来说，情况已经不再是这样了。是的，这真的很酷，我的意思是，我，你看到了这种模式的例子，你知道，就像我知道许多日志记录器（loggers）有不同的后端，所以你换掉后端，用相同的 API 获得不同的功能；或者你正在考虑 SDL，就像回到《毁灭战士》的例子，你知道，有人将《毁灭战士》移植到基于 SDL 运行，所以现在，SDL 有了一百万个不同的后端，
and so it's it's um so yeah that that i think that pattern works really well and so you're just taking that to the next level which is really cool yeah, and exactly like you were saying with the Python libraries and with some of these other things that have pluggable backends, with the stuff that we're doing today, without those hard boundaries of a WebAssembly sandbox, you can't swap those backends without either changing a config file
所以它是，所以是的，我认为这种模式运作得非常好，所以你只是把它提升到了下一个水平，这真的很酷。是的，就像你刚才在 Python 库和一些具有可插拔后端的其他东西中所说的那样，通过我们今天正在做的事情，如果没有 WebAssembly 沙箱的那些硬边界，你就无法在不更改配置文件的情况下交换这些后端，
and then rebuilding a release or changing your code and recompiling it and then redeploying it. Being able to swap that stuff is a compile time decision for too many people, and it shouldn't be. I shouldn't have to architect my services based on the suite of arbitrary stuff i just happen to have lying around on my workstation but that's what happens right i make when i'm in uh experimental mode you know i build my service so it works on my machine and I make a whole bunch of architectural
然后重新构建一个发布版本，或者更改你的代码并重新编译它，然后重新部署它。能够交换这些东西对太多人来说是一个编译时决定，而它不应该是。我不应该根据我碰巧在工作站周围放着的一套随意的乱七八糟的东西来架构我的服务，但这就是发生的事情。当我处于实验模式时，你知道的，我构建我的服务以便它能在我的机器上工作，并在编译时做出一大堆架构决策，这些决策被烘焙到我的工作产品中。我不认为这是一个足够好的模型。我认为我们应该根据我们想要解决的问题来架构我们的解决方案。然后所有这些其他的样板代码，90% 的工作，我再也不想去关心它了。
decisions at compile time that are baked into my work product. And I don't think that's a good enough model. I think we should architect our solutions based on the problems that we want to solve. And then all of this other boilerplate, 90% of our work i don't want to have to care about that anymore yeah that makes sense yeah i love the hot swapping code idea because you know you you know you have like like uh you know as using the lobbying logging framework for an example um you know you have like in python logging you can log to a file you can log across the network you can log different things but all of those different things have to be baked in. And, you
是的，这说得通。是的，我喜欢热插拔代码的想法，因为你知道，你知道，你有一个，就像，你知道，以日志记录框架为例，你知道，像在 Python 日志记录中，你可以记录到文件，你可以跨网络记录，你可以记录不同的东西，但所有这些不同的东西都必须被烘焙进去。而且，你知道，即使你有 10 种不同的选项，并且你可以编写配置文件来选择你想要的 10 种中的哪一种，这 10 种全都在你的源代码中，并且它们全都被锁定了，你无法，你真的没有那种灵活性来，来换掉它们，绝对无法升级它们。这超级超级酷。
know, even if you have 10 different options and you can write a config file to choose which one of the 10 you want, all 10 are in your source code and they're all locked in and you're not able to, you don't really have that flexibility to, to swap them out or definitely not to upgrade them. That is super, super cool. Yeah, that is awesome. So yeah, I think we have a really good handle on WebAssembly and Wasm Cloud. So what's the connection? I know you said that Cosmonaut is fostering web assembly. And so what does that mean day to day? So are you the biggest contributor?
是的，这太棒了。所以，是的，我认为我们对 WebAssembly 和 Wasm Cloud 有了一个很好的掌握。那么联系是什么呢？我知道你说过 Cosmonaut 正在培育 WebAssembly。那么这在日常中意味着什么呢？所以你们是最大的贡献者吗？
Are you managing the community out there? I guess a little bit of everything. Yeah, so we're running the WasmCloud Slack community. And at the moment, we're the largest contributors. But, you know, like I said, it's in everyone's best interest to see the set of tooling and not just the stuff that we're building, but the stuff that everybody is building. It's in everybody's best interest for WebAssembly to gain more traction, to gain more adoption,
你们在管理那里的社区吗？我想每样都有点吧。是的，我们在运营 WasmCloud Slack 社区。目前，我们是最大的贡献者。但是，你知道的，就像我说的，看到这套工具以及不仅是我们构建的东西，还有每个人构建的东西，符合每个人的最大利益。WebAssembly 获得更多牵引力（traction）、获得更多采用、
to get better known so that these tools can be built around it so that the compilers can get smarter to build better hooks into WebAssembly. And then the network effect grows and the WebAssembly ecosystem gets to a mature level where people don't have to worry about, does this thing support this
变得更为人所知，以至于可以围绕它构建这些工具，以便编译器可以变得更聪明，从而在 WebAssembly 中构建更好的钩子（hooks），这符合每个人的最大利益。然后网络效应增长，WebAssembly 生态系统达到成熟水平，人们不必担心，这个东西是否支持我想要用 WebAssembly 做的事情？他们只需选择自己最喜欢的编译器并开始使用，他们选择自己想要的任何运行时。他们在，你知道的，Wasm Cloud 或某个 Lambda 之类的事物之间进行选择。这不再是一个大问题。做出这个决定更多的是个人偏好，而不是其他任何事情。
thing I want to do with WebAssembly? They just pick their favorite compiler and go and they pick whatever runtime they want. They choose between, you know, Wasm cloud or some Lambda thing or whatever. And it's no longer a big deal. Making that decision is more a personal preference than anything else. Cool. And so what is Cosmonic like as a company? So how many folks do you have there? And is it distributed? I mean, I'm sure everyone or, well, there's folks working from home,
酷。那么 Cosmonic 作为一家公司是什么样的？所以你们那里有多少人？它是分布式的吗？我的意思是，我确信每个人或者，好吧，有人在家工作，但那里的总体情况是怎样的？所以目前我们有七个人，我们全都是分布式的。而且就像我说的，还没有太多我可以讨论的事情，但应该相当明显的是，我们正在构建一个建立在 WasmCloud 之上的产品。我们距离能够开始让一些人进入一些私密测试设置以便我们能够获得一些早期反馈已经非常近了。
but what's the general situation like over there? So there's seven of us at the moment and we are all distributed. And like I said, there isn't really much I can discuss yet, but it should be fairly obvious that we're building a product built on top of WasmCloud. And we're pretty close to being able to start getting some people into some private testing setups so that we can get some early feedback. Cool. So there's two sort of threads there. One is if you're out there and you're interested in WebAssembly, the idea sounds really cool, then you want to try it out. Definitely try out Wasm Cloud and also get on the Slack channel. best way to get onto one of these private alpha tests and really work kind of hand in hand with
酷。所以那里有两个方向。一个是，如果你身处其中并且你对 WebAssembly 感兴趣，这个想法听起来真的很酷，那么你想尝试一下。绝对要尝试 Wasm Cloud，还要加入 Slack 频道。加入这些私密 alpha 测试并与 Cosmonic 的人们携手合作以了解那个未来看起来是什么样子的最佳方式。因为这真的是非常非常前沿的。我的意思是，我不认为外面有很多人在考虑跨虚拟机边界移动东西。但我可以亲自告诉你，而且我知道很多人都分享过这个故事，上传巨大的 Docker 容器来完成某件事是痛苦的，你知道的。就像我现在的项目，我们在工作中使用无服务器（serverless），我们使用 Terraform。而且，你知道的，编写脚本并不难。它只是戏剧性（theat）和浪费的时间、周期和网络数据包，去做任何事情。
the folks at Cosmonaut to see kind of what that future looks like. Because this is really, really cutting edge. I mean, I don't think a lot of people out there are thinking about moving things across the VM boundary. But what I can tell you personally, and I know that a lot of people have shared this story is it is painful to upload giant Docker containers, you know, to get something done. Like I have a project now that's we're using serverless, you know, at work, we use Terraform. And and just, you know, the scripting is not hard. It's just theat and and just a wasted time and cycles and network packets to to do anything yeah i mean if you think about that right just just the fact that the docker images themselves are so large and unwieldy prevents a bunch of scenarios like you don't
我的意思是，如果你想想看，仅仅是 Docker 镜像本身如此庞大且难以驾驭这一事实，就阻止了一堆场景，比如你真的不具备在运行时从一个地方动态传输 Docker 镜像到另一个地方的概念，以便让 Docker 镜像运行得更靠近你想要它运行得更靠近的东西，因为你根本做不到，你无法像那样推动 1G 的二进制大对象（blobs）。是的，然后当你考虑计算密度（compute density）时，你知道，计算密度就像是现在云端内容的圣杯，能够将你的所有东西打包到尽可能小的占用空间中，并尽可能少地浪费租来的计算资源。当你要推动的东西是一个 1G 的 Docker 镜像时，那将迫使你在底层虚拟机上做出某些决策，
really have the concept of being able to ship a docker image dynamically at runtime from one place to another in order to make it so that the docker image runs closer to whatever you want it to run closer to because you just can't you can't be pushing around one gig blobs like that yeah and then when you think about compute density right compute density is like that's the holy grail of cloud stuff right now is being able to pack all of your stuff into as small a footprint as possible and waste as little rented compute as possible. And when the thing that you're pushing is a one gig Docker image, then that's going to force you into certain decisions about the underlying VM,
关于该虚拟机的内存容量，因为当你购买云资源时，CPU 和内存通常是耦合的。当你将 1G 或更糟的东西（我见过 8G 的 Docker 镜像）进行比较时。当你将那种大小的 Docker 镜像与 100K 的可移植业务逻辑进行比较时，你可以按需在运行时动态地四处运送它们，而不必担心。你可以在单个虚拟机上的单个进程中运行数千个这样的东西，你知道的，占用与运行 1G Docker 镜像相同的空间。没错。而且 Docker 层的概念极其强大，但它也是一种拐杖，对吧？因为现在你把责任推给了开发人员，说，好吧，在我做 git clone 之前，我想要首先做我所有的 pip install 并获取我所有的包。因为如果我以另一种方式做，那么 Docker 将不断地重新构建那个东西。
about the memory capacity of that VM, because often CPU and memory are coupled when you buy your cloud resources. And when you compare things like the 1 gig or worse, I've seen 8 gig Docker images. When you compare that size Docker image to portable business logic that is 100K, you can ship those around dynamically at runtime on demand and not worry about it. And you can run thousands of those in a single process on a single VM, you know, in the same space as you were running your one gig Docker image. Yep. And the idea of the Docker layers is extremely powerful, but it's also kind of a crutch, right? Because now you're putting the onus on the developer to say, okay, I want to first do all of my pip installs and get all of my packages before I do a git clone. Because if I do it in the other way, then Docker will constantly be rebuilding that thing.
所以你必须以某种方式错开所有东西。它最终变成了一件非常不自然的事情，如果从头到尾阅读你的 Dockerfile，它就像是变化最少的东西一直排到变化最多的东西，这其实并不是一种编写代码的自然方式。相比之下，像这样的一种情况，你说，就像，这无关紧要，因为所有那些外部的东西甚至都不会在 Docker 镜像中。所以我们不必玩所有这些游戏。
So you have to kind of stagger everything. It ends up being this really unnatural thing where your Docker file, if you were to read it top to bottom, it's like the things that change the least down to things that change the most, which is not really a natural way of writing code. Versus something like this where you say, like, it doesn't matter because all of that external stuff is not even going to be in the Docker image. So we don't have to play all of these games yeah when you think one of the other things that comes up a lot is uh the concept of reason to change so when you when you build a thing and you deploy it like what is what's the main reason why i'm sorry about the dog no it's fine what's the main reason why you have to deploy a new version of that thing to production? Is it because your business logic changed? Or is it because something in one of the dependencies that you didn't even want in the first place changed?
是的，当你想到，另一个经常出现的事情是，呃，关于改变的原因的概念——所以当你构建一个东西并部署它时，你知道，主要原因是什么，对不起关于这只狗——不，没关系——你必须将该东西的新版本部署到生产环境中的主要原因是什么？是因为你的业务逻辑改变了？还是因为你甚至一开始就不想要的一个依赖项中的某些东西改变了？
Yeah. 99% of the time, it is not in your business logic. Yep, that's right. of the time, it is not in your business logic. So when you free yourself of that, and so now not only do you have these tiny little portable images that are secure, like I said, we're embedding signatures inside those modules, but those things don't need to change. They don't need to change. They don't even need to change when their to change. They don't need to change. They don't even need to change when their dependencies change.
是的。99% 的情况下，它不是因为你的业务逻辑。是的，那是对的。在大多数情况下，它不是因为你的业务逻辑。所以当你让自己摆脱这一点时，现在你不仅拥有了这些微小的、安全的、可移植的镜像（正如我所说的，我们在这些模块内部嵌入了签名），而且这些东西不需要改变。它们不需要改变。当它们的依赖项改变时，它们甚至不需要改变。
So if you want to swap the database that one of your WebAssembly modules is using from one thing that implements a SQL contract to another, you can do that at runtime without having to rebuild or recompile your code. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Cool. So Cosmotic is just getting started. Are you trying to hire folks or are you really just focused on getting that MVP out? Yes. Yeah, we're always looking for good people. And we're also heads down trying to get the first MVP out.
因此，如果你想将你的某个 WebAssembly 模块正在使用的数据库从实现 SQL 契约的一个东西换成另一个，你可以在运行时做到这一点，而无需重新构建或重新编译你的代码。是的，这完全说得通。酷。所以 Cosmonic 才刚刚开始。你们在试图招聘人员吗，还是真的只是专注于推出那个 MVP？是的。是的，我们一直在寻找优秀的人才。而且我们也在埋头努力推出第一个 MVP。
Got it. What kind of skills are you looking for? So, like I said, we're looking for good people. And so we look at the people that we would want to hire rather than a certain subset of skills. I mean, obviously people need to know how to code and they need to understand distributed systems and things, but you know, language syntax is stuff that can be taught, stuff that can be picked up on the job. So, you know, we are definitely not the type of people that will, you know, make you do a bubble sort on a whiteboard.
明白了。你们在寻找什么样的技能？如我所说，我们在寻找优秀的人才。所以我们看重的是我们想要雇用的人，而不是某种特定的技能子集。当然，人们需要知道如何编写代码，需要理解分布式系统之类的内容，但你知道的，语言语法是可以教的，也是可以在工作中掌握的。所以，我们绝对不是那种会让你在白板上写冒泡排序的人。
Because bubble sorts on whiteboards are not compiled code that runs in production. Yep. Yep. The best interview I think is, is, you know, spend an hour, spend a day with the team. Like here's, here's, and the nice thing about something like Wasm cloud is you can, your interview could be, you know, spend an hour, spend a day with the team. Like here's, and the nice thing about something like WasmCloud is you can, your interview could be, you know, here's an issue, you know, give me a pull request, you know, I'll see you in a week or something. Yeah.
因为白板上的冒泡排序并不是在生产环境中运行的编译代码。没错。没错。我认为最好的面试方式就是，花一个小时，或者花一天时间与团队在一起。比如，像WasmCloud这样的一大优点是，你的面试可以是，比如花一个小时，花一天时间与团队在一起。比如，像WasmCloud这样的一大优点是，你的面试可以是，比如，这是一个问题，给我一个拉取请求，我们一周后见之类的。是的。
You can learn more about a person by listening to how they rubber duck their way through solving a problem than you do by knowing what language they choose to solve that problem in. Yep. Yep. Totally agree. Cool. Yeah. So if you're out there and this sounds awesome to you, it should. Take the time, learn it. And I think this is going to be really, really cool tech. It sounds amazing. Definitely take the time to build something web assembly if you're out there you build anything hit us up on twitter you know you can you can add us and um and you know show off what you've built it's really cool if you get if you get doom working in the browser i know it's been done but uh follow along if you get it working yourself let us know and if this sounds like things uh you know the edge um not to abuse that term but if it sounds like things, you know, the edge, not to abuse that term, but if it sounds like you want to be kind of right on the cutting edge of some really amazing tech, then, you know, get in the Slack channel, get engaged with the community.
通过听一个人如何通过向小黄鸭倾诉来解决问题，你对他的了解要比知道他选择用什么语言来解决问题了解得更多。没错。没错。完全同意。太好了。所以，如果你正在收听，并且觉得这听起来很棒，那它确实很棒。花时间去学习它。我认为这将是非常非常酷的技术。听起来太棒了。如果你正在收听，一定要花时间构建一些WebAssembly相关的东西，如果你构建了任何东西，请在Twitter上联系我们，你知道的，你可以@我们，然后展示你所构建的东西。如果你能让《毁灭战士》在浏览器中运行，那就太酷了，我知道这已经有人做过了，但如果你自己把它做出来了，请让我们知道。如果这听起来像是一些前沿的东西，免得滥用这个词，但如果听起来你想要处于一些真正惊人的技术的最前沿，那么，加入Slack频道，参与到社区中来。
And then ultimately, you know, reach out, reach out to Cosmonic and you might be, you know, the next person they're looking for. So, cool. What is something that is unique about Cosmonic the company so do you uh do you have like a certain off site do you have like a certain story or something that that kind of really sets you apart um so there's a lot of unique things uh one interesting thing is um you know all of our internal release names are from autocorrect mistakes nice okay um another i would say is that all of us are ruthlessly focused on developer experience every one of us has suffered
然后最终，联系Cosmonic，你可能就是他们正在寻找的下一个员工。太好了。作为一家公司，Cosmonic有什么独特之处吗？你们有没有什么特定的公司团建活动，或者有什么独特的故事能真正让你们脱颖而出？嗯，有很多独特的地方。其中一个有趣的事是，我们所有的内部发布版本名称都来自自动纠错的错误。不错，好吧。另一个我想说的是，我们所有人都对开发者体验有着近乎冷酷的专注。我们每个人都经历过
through horrible developer experiences. And so we're basically developers building the product we've always wanted to use, making the company we've always wanted to work for. Very cool. Really well said. Cool. Well, this was amazing.
可怕的开发者体验。所以我们基本上是开发者在构建我们一直想用的产品，打造我们一直想工作的公司。非常酷。说得真好。太好了。嗯，这太棒了。
I mean, I feel like I actually have a really good grasp of WebAssembly, which I think is hard to do over audio in an hour, but you've been able to do it, at least for me. And I know for a lot of folks out there. So I really appreciate your time, Kevin. This is really, really awesome. Thanks so much. I was glad to be here. Music by Eric Barnella. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的意思是，我觉得我对WebAssembly有了很好的理解，我认为这在一小时的音频中很难做到，但你做到了，至少对我来说是这样。我也知道对于听众中的许多人来说也是如此。所以我非常感谢你的时间，Kevin。这真的非常非常棒。非常感谢。很高兴能来到这里。音乐由Eric Barnella提供。《Programming Throwdown》根据知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及混音、改编该作品，但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。